my name is Lisa Snell and I'm the
director of education for the reason
foundation and today it's my great
pleasure to interview Andrew Campanella
who is the president of national school
choice week and we're just going to talk
a little bit about this historic moment
in school choice Andrew would you mind
telling us a little bit about national
school choice week and why school choice
is so important why school choice why do
you guys celebrate it sure well thank
you very much Lisa for having me thanks
to the folks of reason it's always good
to be here national school choice week
celebrates all types of effective
education options for kids from great
traditional public schools to public
charter schools magnet schools private
schools online learning and
homeschooling and we celebrate school
choice because we know that every single
child in this country is different and
every child deserves the opportunity to
go to a school that meets his or her
needs and interests and when we have
choice in everything else in our
American life we should be able to
choose the schools our kids go to so we
celebrate school choice where it exists
and that's millions of more people
choosing schools for their kids than
ever before but national school choice
week also provides a platform for folks
across the country and local communities
to say hey listen I want more choices
for my family can you tell us just a
little bit about the history of national
school choice leak how did you guys get
started where do you see it going you
know I think it's it's really a
testament to the hard work of so many
local organizations schools and
individuals across the country that
national school choice week started out
just a few years ago in 2011 there were
a hundred and fifty events all across
the country and we were incredibly
excited about that because it was the
first year and then we've just seen it
take off and grow because people saw the
positive focus that we put on school
choice during the week there's no
negativity there's no you know
backstabbing and you know any of the
internal warfare that sometimes you see
in the school choice movement is people
getting together coming together working
together for a common purpose and this
year there will be thousands of events
all across the country so let's switch
gears a little bit and talk a little bit
about school choice itself I know you've
been involved in the school choice
movement long
before you were part of school choice
week and you know we're kind of in this
moment of amazing growth you know we
have almost five percent of the public
students in America in charter schools
you know 2.5 million or something kids
what do you think is the most promising
thing about or talk a little bit about
the historical changes in school choice
I mean in say the year 2000 would we
have imagined that kids would have as
many options as they have now and maybe
a little bit about what do you think
some of the most innovative things that
are happening in the school choice
movement well I think you would have
thought in two thousand folks would have
said it would be great if we could get
so many folks not only choosing schools
for their kids and we have millions of
more families actively choosing schools
for their kids now than ever before but
so much demand for school choice and
we're seeing demand for school choice
increase every year what I think is
exciting is that you have growth in
different parts of the school choice
movement sort of growing exponentially
but on parallel tracks you see more
States doing open enrollment for
traditional public schools opening up
public options for families you see
growth in magnet schools they've been
around for a long time doing great work
we're seeing people adopt that model
more public charter schools there's a
waiting list of 1 million kids it's
enough to fill Yankee Stadium I think 25
times if you were to fill it with those
kids on the waiting lists scholarship
programs you seeing those programs grow
enormously every year homeschooling
grows at a rate of two percent online
learning is booming so what we have is
not just one sector of school choice
growing but all sectors so that's what
I'm most excited about is that we are
finally becoming a country where parents
are no longer conditioned to think that
they don't have choices when it comes to
their kids education but they're saying
hey I need a choice I deserve a choice
I've got a choice and everything else
now let's talk about the politics a
little bit and how that's really changed
you know school choice in some ways used
to be branded is kind of a conservative
issue and actually right now we've had
kind of a media thing going on between
Matt Damon and Jeb Bush right where Matt
Damon has been a proponent of public
schools but he sends his kids to private
school
jeb Bush's a proponent of all schools
and he actually sent some of his kids to
public schools can you talk just a
little bit about the how the politics of
school choice have changed over time
well first of all we are seeing more
folks on the left on the progressive
side of the aisle promotes school choice
than ever before whether it's open
enrollment or magnet schools charter
schools scholarship programs online
learning our homeschooling they are
increasingly saying listen this is the
way this is the catalytic reform that
can help all other reforms succeed while
helping kids right away get a better
education in terms of matt damon i think
he makes some good movies and i'll leave
it at that but what really does trouble
me about some of the politics is you
have folks in in New York City who are
you know the authors and antagonists
against school choice they're really the
most vocal people out there they didn't
send their kids to traditional public
schools and yet not only do they oppose
vouchers but they oppose open enrollment
in traditional public schools and I
really question you know what their
motives are because to me that's very
sad so on the one hand the politics
would you say have they improved over
time as far as bipartisanship or do you
think entrenched interest how much power
do entrenched interests still have you
know you're always going to have folks
who are in the bureaucracy and who don't
want change because change would upset
whatever it is they do for a living and
that's just not the same not just for
education reform and school choice but
for everything else but I think that
you're seeing more people cross the
aisle to support school choice than ever
before and the folks who oppose it are
not as widespread as they once were but
I think they're really centered in you
know places like New York frankly and
and you see people writing books about
school choice or going on TV and talking
negatively about it and it's really the
same few people over and over again as
opposed to a bunch of groups all over
the country because support has really
really grown and parents are winning
more battles and they're losing now so
would you say then that the support has
widened and the opposition is narrowed
yeah we found
and doing tracking polls and looking at
what people think that support for
school choice is growing the number of
people on the fence is shrinking but the
number of people who oppose it is
relatively remaining the same so what
you're seeing is people who are on the
fence overwhelmingly going to the side
of supporting school choice so as school
choice week continues year after year
and we're not promoting any specific
policy in fact a lot of folks who join
in with school choice we can't agree on
the specifics of all these different
policies but they agree on the basics
which is giving parents more power more
freedom to make good choices for their
kids we hope that even more people will
come off the fence support school choice
and even convince some of those skeptics
yeah I mean it does seem like when you
have examples of very organized efforts
against school choice like recently in
Louisiana right there was coming from
the president's administration an
organized effort to curtail the
Louisiana program and it does seem like
public outcry from across the board and
you have to look at an effort like that
and say not only what a terrible
situation that was but look at it and
say who actually came out and supported
that lawsuit you can't really find that
many people who were you know issuing
press releases holding rallies holding
events to say yeah let's sue to get rid
of a scholarship program that's helping
low-income kids go to great schools
you're not seeing that you might see
some snarky blog posts in favor of it
but that's all so let's just wrap up
with what do you think the biggest
challenge for the school choice movement
is and what do you think the future
holds the biggest challenge for the
school choice movement is continuing to
get along there's so many people who
support school choice in a variety of
different forms and it's easy to say
that just because you didn't agree with
one organization on one policy that
you're never going to talk to them again
but if folks want to advance educational
opportunity they need to see the forest
through the trees work together
collaborate together recognize that they
might not always get their way every
single time but a cohesive movement that
gets along and works together there's a
lot more effective than one that is
factionalized and fractured so that's
the biggest threat the biggest challenge
what do I think the future holds for
school choice I think the future holds
just absolute tremendous growth and so
many more opportunities for kids then we
could have imagined and you know we
can't write any of the choices off there
are so many great options within the
public system good options in the
private system online which could be
public or private and homeschooling
never forget the homeschoolers so to me
it's really one of the best parts of our
country right now is seeing people
finally making good choices because
they're able to make those good choices
for their kids when it comes to going to
where they'd send their kids to school